vamos a ver unos ejemplos de cómo
resolver problemas que involucren
trabajo imaginen un bote de basura de 4
kilogramos este bote de basura está muy
sucio así que alguien le ate a una
cuerda y jala del bote con una fuerza de
50 newtons la fuerza de fricción
cinética en el bote de basura mientras
se desliza es de 30 newtons el bote de
basura se desliza en el suelo unos 10
metros vamos a tratar de encontrar el
trabajo realizado por cada fuerza en el
bote de basura mientras se desplazan
estos 10 metros para encontrar el
trabajo realizado por cada fuerza
debemos recordar la fórmula de trabajo
el trabajo es igual a efe por d por el
coseno de t está donde está es el ángulo
que se forma entre la fuerza que realiza
el trabajo y la dirección en la que se
mueve el bote de basura aquí tenemos
cuatro fuerzas involucradas tenemos la
fuerza de tensión la fuerza normal la
fuerza gravitacional y la fuerza de
fricción cinética al encontrar el
trabajo realizado por todas estas
fuerzas
el desplazamiento va a ser de 10 metros
el valor de la fuerza y el ángulo entre
la fuerza y la dirección del
desplazamiento va a ser diferente para
cada una de las fuerzas
por ejemplo para encontrar el trabajo
realizado por la fuerza de atención
ponemos el tamaño de la fuerza que es de
50 newtons el desplazamiento son 10
metros y ya que la fuerza de tensión
apunta a la misma dirección que el
desplazamiento del bote de basura el
ángulo entre la fuerza de tensión y esa
dirección del movimiento va a ser de 0
grados y ya que el coseno de 0 es 1 el
trabajo realizado por la fuerza de
tensión es de 500 jules positivos para
encontrar el trabajo realizado por la
fricción usamos el tamaño de la fuerza
de fricción 30 newtons el desplazamiento
sigue siendo de 10 metros y ya que la
fuerza de fricción apunta en sentido
contrario a la dirección del movimiento
el ángulo entre la dirección del
desplazamiento y el de la fricción es de
180 grados y ya que el coseno de 180
grados es igual a menos 1 el trabajo
realizado por la fuerza de fricción
es de 300 jules negativos ahora veamos
el trabajo realizado por la fuerza
gravitacional la fuerza de gravedad es m
por g así que la fuerza de gravedad es
de 4 kilogramos por 9.8 metros por
segundo al cuadrado que es de 39.2
newtons el desplazamiento sigue siendo
de 10 metros
pero el ángulo entre la fuerza
gravitacional y el movimiento del bote
de basura es de 90 grados y ya que el
coche no de 90 grados es igual a cero
tenemos que el trabajo realizado por la
fuerza gravitacional es de 0 o sea no
realiza ningún trabajo sobre el bote de
basura de manera similar si queremos
encontrar el trabajo realizado por la
fuerza normal el ángulo entre la
dirección del movimiento y la fuerza
normal es de 90 grados también y ya
vimos que el coche no de 90 grados es
cero así que la fuerza normal no realiza
trabajo sobre el bote de basura esto
tiene sentido ya que las fuerzas que son
perpendiculares al movimiento no pueden
realizar trabajo alguno sobre ese objeto
y es así como podemos encontrar el
trabajo realizado por fuerzas
individuales y si queremos conocer el
trabajo neto realizado sobre este bote
de basura solo tenemos que sumar el
trabajo realizado por cada una de estas
fuerzas por lo que el trabajo neto va a
hacer de 200 jours positivos y ahora que
conocemos el trabajo neto realizado
sobre el bote de basura
debemos usar el principio de trabajo
energía para encontrar la rapidez de el
bote de basura después de que se deslizó
los 10 metros el principio de trabajo
energía dice que el trabajo neto
realizado en un objeto es igual al
cambio en la energía cinética de este
objeto
así que 200 jules positivos van a ser
igual a la diferencia en la energía
cinética y si suponemos que el bote de
basura comenzó en un estado de reposo lo
que parece razonable podemos quitar este
término de aquí ya que la velocidad
inicial es de 0 y podemos despejar la
velocidad final de este bote de basura
que es resulta ser de 10 metros por
segundo ahora digamos que tomamos el
bote de basura y lo levantamos con una
velocidad constante por una distancia de
2 metros para poder levantar el bote de
basura con una velocidad constante
tendremos que empujar con una fuerza
igual a la del peso de este bote de
basura lo que quiere decir que tenemos
que empujar hacia arriba con una fuerza
de 39.2 newtons así que para encontrar
el trabajo
realizado por la fuerza que estamos
ejerciendo la fuerza va a ser de 39.2
newtons el desplazamiento es de 2 metros
y el ángulo entre la fuerza y el
desplazamiento es de 0 grados ya que la
dirección de la fuerza es la misma que
la dirección del movimiento así que hay
trabajo realizado al levantar este bote
de basura es de 78.4 dispositivos para
encontrar el trabajo realizado por la
fuerza de gravedad
podemos usar la fuerza de gravedad que
de nuevo es 39.2 newtons el
desplazamiento sigue siendo de 2 metros
pero el ángulo entre la dirección del
desplazamiento y la dirección de la
fuerza es de 180 grados ya que el
desplazamiento apunta hacia arriba y la
fuerza de gravedad apunta hacia abajo
así que el trabajo realizado por la
fuerza de gravedad es de menos 78.4
jules lo que significa que el trabajo
neto realizado sobre el bote de basura
es de cero jules lo que tiene sentido ya
que como levantamos el bote de basura
con una velocidad constante
cambio en la energía cinética de este